[Musique]
alors il est où l'échantillon piotr
boris volkov n'est pas le genre de
personne à qui il faut chercher des
noises
[Musique]
piotr a vendu à sam sonate des diamants
médiamat des fois c'est de la très
grande qualité nouvelle tunique
il est faux le plus beau que j'ai jamais
eu vous devez être plus sélectifs parce
que les amis que vous avez aujourd'hui
vous trompent ceux qui j'imagine est un
problème parmi d'autres ce que vous
aviez à faire c'était de vous procurer
un échantillon 1 un petit diamant
je vous dis méfiez-vous rentrée avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
l'impression que vous avez des ennuis je
voulais juste faire appel à votre
patience
la patience monsieur il sait comme
l'oxygène dans une pièce close
peu importe combien vous en avait au
départ vous finissez toujours par en
manque et on va pouvoir commencer
[Musique]
les diamants sont ils morts
tu me détestes
[Musique]